I want to let you know today that, uh, there's
an increasingly desperate caravan,
people who have decided they simply cannot
stay in their home countries anymore economic
conditions and the sort of realities on the
ground are pushing them across the border
once and for all from the United States into
Canada where they can fall, hopefully find
cheaper healthcare and cheaper medications
than in the United States.
Uh, there was a story some months ago I did
about a daily caravan of Americans that crosses
the southern border into Mexico for inexpensive
but good quality dentistry in Mexico.
And I think also it was a optometry in addition
to dentistry.
And there's a new report this week in Newsweek
about a so called caravan.
And I'm using the term sort of satirically
people, Americans who are crossing into Canada
looking for more affordable health care for
type one diabetes.
Uh, because the same drugs that are used to
treat diabetes in the United States are used
in Canada.
Uh, and they're much cheaper in Canada.
Insulin can be purchased in Canada for about
a 10% of what it costs in the United States.
And at some of, you know, since the mid nineties,
the price of insulin has increased more than
1100% according to data from Truven health
analytics.
But as you also probably know, wages have
not increased 1100% since the mid nineties.
And this is of course, in addition to what
most people are paying kind of in total for
their health care, which is health insurance,
premiums and copays and uncovered medical
expenses, et Cetera, et cetera.
Now the FDA, um, is officially taking the
position that it is risky to travel outside
the United States for insulin because the
safety of the insulin might be compromised.
The effectiveness of foreign insulin might
not be as high.
And of course that could apply to some countries,
but in Canada it's fine.
And this is just a truly horrible reality
and an optional problem of the system that
we have, right?
The profit motive and the political impasse
has fixed this issue and it prevents us from
actually dealing with it.
And it's merely a decision we have to make.
I mean we, we know, uh, exactly how this can
be dealt with.
The, these are relatively simple math problems,
actuarial problems and mostly of political
will.
Um, and I guess this is a good opportunity.
I mean, while we're at it, I should dispel
the notion that health care around the world
is terrible and unreliable and dangerous.
It's not exactly what the FDA is saying when
they say you should go to gotta.
Be really careful if you go anywhere else
for insulin.
Obviously there are many places in the world
where I would try to avoid having to get healthcare
services, uh, if traveling or whatever the
case may be.
But there are so many countries, even countries
considered so called third world or developing
countries often have very good health coverage
at very, very reasonable rates.
Belize is an example.
Belize has plenty of problems.
The national income is about 8,000 PPP dollars,
a purchasing power parity dollars.
So, um, uh, we don't even have to get to what
that means.
Just think about 8,000 US dollars.
Is that the sort of uh, um, national income
per person?
It's not a rich country, but care is very
good.
And many Americans retire in Belize, partially
because they can get good, cheap healthcare.
Argentina, my home country riddled with problems,
I mean NASA of economic problems, but at private
hospitals and private clinics where you would
be paying for care as a visiting American,
uh, it is extraordinarily cheap by our standards
and you still get good care.
Some of the public hospitals in Argentina,
particularly outside of the Capitol City,
not the best, but for what we're used to paying,
going to private hospitals in Argentina would
be very accessible and very good.
Even in Mexico.
Mexico is of interest more and more, uh, for
Americans to retire to and for medical tourism.
And a lot of websites now are solely dedicated
to how can you legally get resident status
in Mexico.
It's of course, very stratified between regions
in Mexico in terms of what is available, but
really excellent hospitals and care and many
parts of the country, including Mexico City.
So in any case, the American economy would
be better off if American's didn't feel the
need to go to other countries for care because
you'd be keeping those dollars here.
You'd be funding people's salaries here in
the United States.
Fortunately for us, Mexico and Canada are
welcoming to people from other countries who
come from countries that have third world
health insurance systems like we have in the
United States.
And we know how to fix it.
Okay.
We have plans for how it can be done.
We know what it would cost, but we remain
stuck in this decades long.
I mean, it's really like a century long impasse,
which dates back to the period between World
War One and World War II, where we were starting
to go in the direction of a more European
model on healthcare.
And then that idea was smeared as being too
much like Germany at a time when we weren't
getting along with Germany for good reasons,
by the way.
Uh, and it's been downhill ever since.
And you know where we are today in 2019 but
at least Canada, is there a for type one diabetes
sufferers to go and get inexpensive and still
reliable quality insulin.